en train de la tôle france et jean paul
sartre andré gide a porté pendant un bon
quart de siècle l'image du grand
écrivain engagé dans son temps avec
cette nuance dans le cas de gide c'est
que l'engagement n'était pas seulement
politique ou morale il mettait en jeu le
comportement intime et les penchants
homosexuels
gide se livre sans fard dans son fameux
journal dont gallimard dans la
bibliothèque de la pléiade présente la
première partie en une nouvelle édition
éric martin n'a pas tort dans son
introduction de rapprocher le journal du
grand oeuvre de marcel proust
contemporain de gide à deux ans près à
la recherche du temps perdu par la
notation quotidienne chez gide par la
fresque romanesque chez proust
il s'agit d'emprisonner le passé et ces
deux démarches sont tout à fait
concertée gide est animé de la fureur
d'écrire et de penser
il veut tout lire tout connaître combler
aussi les exigences d'un désir
omniprésents ils n'arrêtent pas
d'évoquer la nécessité d'une morale
écrivant par exemple il faut se faire
irréprochable mais la chair à ces
contraintes il songe à octave athmane et
à bien d'autres
il mesure également son orgueil le
secret de mon ennui dans rome
je ne me trouve pas intéressant et
pressent sa propre hypocrisie admirant a
contrario la franchise de son ami guéant
le journal exercice de conciliation
sinon de réconciliation avec soi donne
le goût de la liberté